[Music]
hey everyone it is jessie from the tasty
team and today i'm gonna be testing out
five famous celebrity natural recipes to
see which one is actually the best on
today's lineup we have recipes from
Chrissy Teigen Guy Fieri Alton Brown
Rachael Ray and even women by Snoop Dogg
we measure out all the ingredients
exactly his recipe says - we got three
girlfriends taste them and a blind taste
test so was best not recipe let's find
out first up is Chrissy Teigen she
starts by scattering thinly sliced
shallots in a heatproof baking dish and
pouring oil over them so they're
completely submerged take that pop it in
the microwave and you're gonna cook this
just until they start to turn golden
brown and get crispy this happens fast
so keep an eye on it after that you're
gonna strain it and then put the
Christmas shots on a paper towel-lined
plate and save those for later a little
bit of salt next you're gonna heat some
oil in a skillet and you're gonna add
onions and cook them until caramelized
this takes a while but be patient
towards the end you're gonna throw in
some didn't you sliced garlic and cook
that for just a minute longer so all the
flavors meld together transfer that all
onto a plate and and a little bit of oil
back into the pan add a ton of sliced
mushrooms and cook those just until all
their water starts to purge and they get
nice and brown to that you're gonna add
oregano cayenne chili powder salt and
pepper and cook it for just a bit longer
so all the flavors get nice and aromatic
and the onions back stir it all together
season it up put a little bit of salt
and pepper and take that and part right
on top of some chips scatter those
around and add shredded pepper jack
cheese as well as shredded sharp white
cheddar add some jalapenos and pop in
and up once that's out of the oven
garnish with a bit more jalapenos some
tomatoes scallions and the crispy shell
cement and there you have it
chrissy teigen vegetarian nachos
we alright let's check this out here
okay I'm a big fan of nachos so these
better be good I'm seeing mushroom which
I'm not super jazzed about look
promising
smells like an omelet okay so this is
definitely not like a
ammos Qdoba Chipotle kind of classic
nacho situation I just think it's like a
hard no and the mushrooms in nachos I
was kind of surprised that it tastes as
good as it does mean that there is no
meat it holds up its a nacho I would
call this a nacho it's not like
offensive but it's also not like exactly
what I think imma Joe is up next is Guy
Fieri with a Italian nachos which is
perplexing because he starts by frying
wonton skins and a heavy-bottomed skills
until they're nice puffy and browned I
flip them halfway just so they cook
evenly and then we're gonna set those
aside next up he makes an Italian style
salsa by combining peppers tomatoes red
onions parsley capers pepper juice from
the jars of peppers came in minced
garlic olive oil and seasoned it up with
a black pepper and a pinch of salt set
that aside and in a skillet heat up
olive oil and add buff brown beef and
Italian turkey sauces cook that up until
nice and brown and transfer it onto a
plate to that same pan you're gonna add
onions and garlic and cook it all up
until fragrant add the meat back to that
mix it all up and set that aside in a
separate bowl add ricotta cheese sour
cream and mix it up until smooth put it
into a ziplock baggie and set that aside
we'll use that to pipe it on later
bring in your wonton chips half of them
and cover it with the ground meat
mixture top that with shredded
mozzarella cheese and do that one more
time with the remaining chips the
remaining filling and even more cheese
pop that in the oven until it's nice and
melted and you're gonna garnish it with
salami basil prepared salsa the sour
cream mixture which you're gonna pipe in
a zigzag and garnish the whole thing
with green onions there you have it guy
tailing style nachos
oh okay Kieffer's on it what do we call
the cured meats I don't know exactly
which one this is but they're only
delicious this kind of reminds me of
like DiGiorno it's no shame to destroy I
can't tell what is going on but there is
something that went on here oh wow
that's nice I have like a very like a
pizza eternities it's good it's really
good actually I can't really taste the
cheese which I don't like
I don't know maybe like an Italian nacho
or something like that this is the way
to go it goes a nacho so far this is
like a reference to a nacho this is a
nacho concept but I don't think it's
about show up next is Alton Brown and as
usual he is a crazy hack to make him
just perfect
you take crumpled up tin foil put them
on all four sides of a tray and then you
put a layer of chips down top each chip
with one piece of jalapeno some red
onions and sprinkle both cheddar cheese
and Oaxaca cheese on top of each one so
every bite has a perfect ratio of
ingredients take a wire rack and bounce
it on top of those four balls you made
and do the same exact thing layering
each chip with all the ingredients so
every bite is perfect more cheese and
one more layer so you have three layers
total this sounds a bit ridiculous and
it's pretty time-consuming but maybe it
is worth it
take the whole entire tray and carefully
take it in the oven and bake them until
nice and melted put them on a serving
tray and sprinkle them with chopped
fresh oregano and serve them with salsa
sour cream and guacamole and that's it
Alton Brown's crazy hack for making
nachos there's like Jillian Michaels not
jealous oh oh right off the bat let's
say he's gonna be a little spicier than
the last ones we got a little jalapeno
hanging right down the top it's so
sparse there's so few ingredients on top
of the actual chip this is more like
chips and dip
rather than nachos individual jalapenos
on each chip gross that's nice
this is more of like a classic nacho I
feel oh my god
it's so spicy yeah spice in the jalapeno
is really coming through now
that's nice though this kind of nacho is
the kind of mantra that I would make
like after school or an after-school
snack
sour cream really helps cool down Matt
jalapeno that word of this a restaurant
I would be disappointed because I can go
to the store get some Tostitos I do like
how each one of them is like already I
pre constructed in a way and then you
get to choose whatever toppings you want
on the side I feel like it would
definitely take a little bit of extra
effort but all-in-all it's definitely
worth it next up is Rachael Ray she
starts by making a homemade pico by
combining tomatoes jalapeno white onions
chopped cilantro and a bit of salt in a
small bowl just so it's all evenly
combined set that aside and heat olive
oil in a skillet add garlic onions
jalapeno and cook that up until fragrant
to that add ground sirloin and break
that up so it doesn't clump together add
salt chilli powder cumin cayenne pepper
and stir that in add black beans mix it
all up and you're gonna keep this on low
just until we're ready to assemble in
another pot start melting some butter
and add flour to it to create a roux
pour in some milk and whisk that up
until it starts to thicken up a little
bit add shredded pepper jack cheese stir
that in until it's nice and creamy and
take that cheese and pour it right over
a layer of two different color chips top
it with the meat mixture the homemade
Piku sour cream scallions black olives
pimentos slices of fresh avocado in a
bit of hot sauce and Rachael Ray's
nachos are done okay this looks like
what I want it to look like so we got
some meat we got some beans we got some
cheese we got some avocado just from the
looks of this it is my kind of nacho
going to me it has mmm the flavoring is
very nice like the seasoning on the meat
is good under this one I like this one
the only thing that's a little weird is
the cheese I'm not sure if it's like
actual cheese or if it's like mopely
case that were step up I think the beans
really does it usually that much a good
touch this is the most like traditional
nacho
so far I feel like it's um even though
it is heavily packing I kind of I kind
of like that feel like it's overly
packed and the way where it's just kind
of super sloppy this
layers of flavor this has all the
elements of what I think a nacho has a
web black beans so how's black beans
that's a plus for me but taste is on the
money last but not least is Snoop Dogg
he starts by heating some oil and adding
ground beef to a pan seasoning it up
with chili powder cumin garlic powder
onion powder salt and pepper and cooking
that all up until it's nice and browned
using a slotted spoon transfer that out
just so you don't have a ton of oil left
over take that make sure and scatter it
on top of chips that are on aluminum
foil lined baking tray top with corn
black beans sliced jalapeno and both
Monterey Jack cheese and cheddar cheese
pop in the oven so it gets nice and
melty and while that's happening smash
two avocados with the juice of one lime
and season up with salt and pepper bring
back your nachos top it with the smashed
avocado as well as sour cream diced
tomatoes chopped fresh cilantro and
sliced scallions and that's it Snoop
Dogg suited and booted loaded nachos got
some corn I love corn like if I did a
Google search of nachos I feel like this
is the most accurate so far um I don't
love corn in my nachos got a really good
punch a lemon in this one or lime is
something acidic something that really
just jumped out at me there's not really
a lot of flavor I will say there's a lot
of guacamole when it's on a nacho and it
covers everything then it becomes like a
guacamole chip basically I don't know
what that is probably cilantro or
something something very very fresh very
nice
that adds a pretty nice element to these
nachos it's just like plain beans plain
corn cheese chips and ground beef I'm a
little unimpressive this one they got
all the elements I would want plus the
extra supplies of the corn yeah I do
enjoy it maybe a little too much wok for
my taste
so out of the five notches what I ate
number four is my favorite because it's
the most traditional nacho plate has all
the elements I want it has a good level
of spice shows all of them I'm missing
something and I have everything right
really that's a prize okay Rachel I see
you out of the five that I tried I think
the one that I like the best is number
four it accomplishes the assignment it's
a nacho it has all the elements they're
all evenly distributed I like that one
the best
Rachael Ray 30-minute meals my girl I'm
proud of that I'm proud of that you know
I grew up watching her love her Empire
and yeah I'm proud to say that I'm a
Rachael Ray Stan out of the five nachos
that I had I might disappoint the people
but I say I'm gonna go with the
unorthodox nachos number two though they
were completely different when it comes
to any other notches that I've tasted
and I really like that really
reminiscent of like pizza had like an
Italian flavor and it was really like a
cool spin of nachos I haven't tried
before I picked Italian nachos
dude that's the name is on the money
just like the matches were guy tallying
nachos for the win so there you have it
Rachael Ray has the best nachos recipe
so which recipe should we test next let
us know in the comments
[Music]
oh yes